it's that time of the year when losers
lecture us on unacceptable Halloween
costume for kids that aren't even their
own this time Redbook editors the man
you don't let your little girl dress as
Disney's Moana they right maybe think
about using this Halloween to teach your
kids about the importance of cultural
sensitivity if your kid wears a racist
costume you're kind of wearing it too so
some miserable editor who can't even put
her name on the piece accuses you of
racism when in fact she's the racist for
promoting cultural segregation a child
dresses up as a fictional character
because she loves that character rather
than encouraging empathy red book
encourages separatism so all races
should just stay in their Lane I guess a
Polynesian child can't be snow white and
what if this were not about ethnicity
but gender what if I wanted to dress up
as Moana or Wonder Woman or susan b
anthony would read book deny my
non-binary gender identity how cisgender
can you be you bigots
that's identity politics it turns on
itself and gobbles all the weak thinkers
up and yet the media still embraces this
junk why is that well I worked in
magazines I know
these editors despise their feeble
contributions to society so they used
attention-seeking pronouncements of
moral superiority to impress their peers
fact is a child dressing up as mallanna
doesn't make her racist it means she
sees past ethnicity to choose someone to
emulate yes unlike these nameless red
book editors I'd go as one of them on
Halloween but we have enough zombies out
there Flemmi Kimberly oh god you were
doing so well
I was shot myself in the foot give me
such around the table I think that was
fantastic one of your best monologue
Thank You all-time I mean children get
it they're more evolved than the rest of
us to be honest because they're not
second-guessing it they are pure in
thought and love and emotion to say this
is somebody I like watching whether it's
boys or girls love Milan everybody loves
iguana they did this now but this like
hyper cultural sensitivity the
on Saturday Night Live you had like you
know Melissa McCarthy faked Spicer doing
the whole travel ban with the mallanna
doll and be like Oh mallanna we're
reading all your emails and you're not
right boom and they tossed Moana and the
box you're not gonna get in yeah then
they did regular Barbie etc so that's
what's happening here it's like a
knee-jerk reaction yeah you know one you
wanted to go as Madonna but they're not
that's it because you're not a woman you
can't go Jesse wouldn't go with me
putting up with that you know so I was
listening because III don't like
political correctness but I was thinking
as I was listening to you what would you
say about blackface where you had white
people who for much of our history were
you know thought oh great I'll just act
like a stupid black person I'm not black
people and you know oh if you complain
about it you're politically so a little
girl dressing up as Moana is the
equivalent of blackface no I'm saying
it's a cultural appropriation is the
term used these days but is it the case
that if you put on a headdress you say
oh it's just a hat you don't think oh no
but to the people who created it it has
great significance a fictional character
okay you're not putting on black no
that's it's complete it was a great
monologue and I'm glad you did it
because I'm gonna use it to plug my
weekend show we are